ont été reçus les propos d' emmanuel
macron jean marc flipo porte-parole de
debout la france et philippa mazuel
président du parti des citoyens
européens en débattent avec nous
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france philippe mazuel
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
cette conférence de presse qu est ce qui
vous a marqué
bien ce qui m'a marqué c'est d'abord le
certains manques dans cette cette
conférence de presse un manque flagrant
sur la question de la démocratie en
europe parce que nous souhaitons
participer et robin nous souhaitons sur
la partie transnationales nous
souhaitons avancer vers une europe plus
unie une europe politique mais on voit
bien qu'on peut pas avancer sur la
souveraineté dans beaucoup de domaines
sans accompagner par un processus
politique et je regrette que le
président de la république qui se
targuait de ne défendre démocraties
européennes et torpillé le système que
nous avons mis en place en 2014 c'est à
dire la l'élection comme président de la
commission européenne ce terreau chef de
l'exécutif européen de la personne qui
gagnait les élections européennes dans
qu'en 2019 c'est une honte fait webber
qui était le chef de file des
conservateurs européens qui a gagné les
élections qui arrivent en premier et
monsieur macron a préféré 20 devrait
pour que l'on nomme aux smartphones
airlines ce qui est un déni de
démocratie donc ça c'est extrêmement
grave et je souhaite que on aille de
remettre sur rails de la démocratie
européenne à partir du mois d'avril
lorsque le président de la république
aura changé de façon à préparer les
électeurs de 1024 que nous ayons
vraiment un président de la commission
européenne une président la commission
européenne choisi par le citoyen c'est
un point absolument clé un jour fait
réagir vos os et jean marc flipo après
c'est presque deux heures de conférence
de presse des manuels macro qu'est ce
que vous avez retenu de son de son
discours
jugé refuge continue surtout que c'était
un cocktail de projets qui étaient déjà
en route que tu avais déjà été lancées
par les précédentes présidences et de
déclarations d'intention donc là on est
jeu je vois rien de concret j'ai pas
j'ai pas entendu de mesures techniques
concrètes qui pouvait effectivement être
réalisées sur la durée de la présidence
française alors que la présidence
française normalement traditionnellement
est très importante pour notre part nos
deux continents
j'ai remarqué aussi une certaine forme
de constat d'échec de cette de cette
union européenne que ce soit sur des
matières de en matière de défense ce
soit en matière de déficit commercial
soit en matière de numérique et l'a fait
un peu la liste de tout ce qui
fonctionnait mal dans cette dans cette
union européenne et puis sur son sur son
objectif que vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure qui est de passer d'une europe
des coopérations inter européenne à une
europe puissance qui assume sa certaine
forme de souveraineté moi je me suis
intéressé à l'euro depuis je suis très
jeune j'ai l'impression d'entendre des
déclarations d'intention 1979 en a pas
on n'a pas vraiment on n'a pas vraiment
progressé de ce point de vue là ensuite
j'ai entendu un très mauvais signal
adressé notamment un à doa nouveaux
voisins allemands concernant la remise
en question de de la règle des 3% alors
je sais que c'est pas une règle à
laquelle à laquelle je tiens
particulièrement en revanche je trouve
relativement maladroit de l'annoncer
comme ça de cette manière lors de lors
de sa prise de présidence parce qu'on
sait d'ores et déjà que szavay a suscité
une opposition frontale de la part de la
part de nos voisins que ce soit au
niveau de la chancellerie ou même de la
delacourt de la cour constitutionnelle
et plancherait ainsi les bases elle vous
appeler à plus de démocratie européenne
est ce que l'un des trois axes la mise
en avant par emmanuel macron dans sa
conférence de presse bâtir une europe a
time élèves que ça ne va pas dans ce
sens là je le cite les propos d'
emmanuel macron qui souhaite faire de
cette présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne un grand moment
d'humanisme européen il évoque une
europe plus efficace plus proche de nos
citoyens plus simple si ce sont surtout
de belles paroles qu'est-ce que vous
attendriez pour être plus proche des
citoyens qu'il faut donner la parole aux
citoyens c'est à dire que il faut lors
des élections européennes que les
citoyens puissent choisir le président
de la commission je dirais même que
doivent pouvoir choisir
les commissaires européens il faut
réfléchir à cette façon de
éventuellement délire aussi les
commissaires européens voilà donc ça
c'est un certain point il faut il faut
faire des choses extrêmement concrète
est allé au delà de l'union européenne
d'aujourd'hui il faut essayer de d'aller
vers une république européenne entre les
pays qui ont envie d'aller de l'avant
envie de plus de démocratie et ça on n'a
pas cette personne qui n'a pas du tout
été présenté par le président de la
république
il ya un autre point que je regrette
dans sedan dans cette conférence ils
vont d'un parent tellement parlé du
social et on peut pas faire lors des
citoyens 100 m plus le social au centre
du au centre du débat alors certes le
présent dans la vie qu'à parler d'eux
des revenus d'aller vers un revenu
minimal le minimum pardon mais je pense
qu'il aurait du coq est aussi le droit
du travail européen qui doit être
beaucoup plus harmonisée et si nous
devons commencer par un métier
éminemment européen sur lequel devrions
travailler pour le rapprochement des
salaires ce sont les routiers les
chauffeurs routiers qui constamment si
en europe il a été longuement question
jean marc flipo
de ce premier axe longo défini par
emmanuel macro qui souhaitent une
souveraineté mettre en place une
souveraineté stratégiques européennes
une europe capable de maîtriser ses
frontières de les protéger il a évoqué
une réforme de l'espace schengen avec de
nouveaux mécanismes de protection des
frontières comment est-ce que
avait reçu cette proposition
c'est ce que nous réclamons depuis au
moins tout de suite le micro du poignant
les candidats à la présidence de la
république depuis 2012 c'est quelque
chose qui sépare et qui devait couler de
fait dès la création de la mise en
oeuvre de schengen en 1995 on est
presque 30 ans plus tard on est toujours
dans la même manière dans cette espèce
de l'impossibilité de contrôler ses
frontières extérieures de l'europe on en
a des exemples tous les jours donc la
ccq rappela quelques elle est articulée
à l'heure actuelle ne fonctionne pas et
ce que je ramasse en manquant cela
d'échec donc il faut revenir selon lui
nous sommes un parti souverainiste
on n'en fait pas mystère donc nous ce
qui nous importe si on reprend l'ordre
des priorités vous c'est que vous citez
ça en numéro 1 nous ne citons en numéro
1 des priorités l'europe même qui a été
relégué à la fin du discours du
président de la république en plus de
sacs des considérations extrêmement
inquiétant selon moi qui vise à à
réécrire une histoire européenne comme
si l'histoire de l'europe n'était pas
déjà dit que ce n'était pas déjà écrite
par qui vise à à financer des
journalistes soit disant indépendant
alors qu'il était jugé indépendant par
un organe européen donc ce serait les
formes de journalisme officiel de
l'union européenne qu'on n'irait
subventionnés dans des pays membres en
feintant des signes on appelle ça doit
pas devenir l'union soviétique je pense
qu'il faut revenir effectivement à des
principes démocratiques avant de revenir
au niveau du citoyen les français en
rejeter cette europe bureaucratique
quelques on nous impose aujourd'hui et
qu'on veut renforcer les françaises sont
exprimés extrêmement clairement contre
ce fonctionnement là pour autant les
français sont très européen et nous nous
pensons que comme disait le général de
gaulle en fait pas une lettre avec des
oeufs durs mais nations européennes sont
des zones sur les européens utilisent
déjà leur parlement ne pourrais très
bien évoluer selon nous vers une
délégation au parlement européen de
parlement de parlementaires nationaux il
retrouverait une cohérence entre eux
la volonté
démocratique des citoyens qui s'exprime
lors des élections législatives
nationales et qui viennent qui vont
porter les projets de chaque pays au
parlement européen a filé pas ce duel
sur ce point de cette souveraineté
stratégiques européennes décrite par
emmanuel macron il a donc été question
de cette réforme de l'espace schengen je
vais vous laisser réagir et il est aussi
revenu sur la politique de défense
européenne il faut avancer sur sur cette
politique n'est pas resté très très
longuement sur ce point là qu'il a aussi
mis en avant la nécessaire stabilité et
prospérité du voisinage de l'union
européenne indiquant qu'un sommet serait
organisée entre l'union africaine et
l'union européenne ainsi qu'une
conférence sur les balcons quel est
votre regard sur cette première
thématique défend le chef de l'état
alors d'abord sur la sur les frontières
je crois qu'il faut aller véritablement
vers une politique européenne d une une
police européenne aux frontières et avec
une politique d'asile commune et
évidemment des accords avec les pays
d'origine pour pour pouvoir renvoyer les
personnes qui sont là illégalement en
échange de quoi nous accueillons un
certain nombre de denis cans réguliers
sur des emplois qui sont à pourvoir sur
la question de l'art de la défense
je pense que j'aurais aimé qu'on parle
d'un concept qui est important pour le
parti citoyen européen tce c'est le la
diplomatie pacifique c'est à dire que
nous devons aller vers une diplomatie
européenne qui ne soit pas basée sur la
vente d'armes comme on l'a vu ces jours
ci à des à des dictatures mais qu' on
s'impose de de ne vendre des armes cas
des pays et démocratique ce qui ce qui
implique nous devons développer notre
politique européenne d'armement pour
pour avoir une harmonisation de nos
armées et pouvoir ainsi vendre notre
propre matériel en europe à des pays
démocratiques ce qui manque beaucoup je
trouve dans le discours de monsieur
macro aujourd'hui c'est la sécurité en
europe il a parlé évidemment de
l'afrique c'est extrêment important mais
il a très peu parlé la sécurité en
europe moi je suis très inquiet de la
situation aujourd'hui je pense que qu'il
faut organiser une conférence européenne
au niveau avec tous les européens et les
américains les canadiens aient constitué
européen évidemment c'est évidemment la
russie l'ukraine le belarus la turquie
de façon à avoir commandé construisons
la sécurité de l'europe de demain est
posée notamment il faut poser un moment
donné le rôle et les lignes de l'otan
qui est un qui me semble être un des
points clés de la difficulté aujourd'hui
avec avec reka russie notamment et dans
cette ce débat sur la sécurité en europe
ne devrions comme en 1973 avec les
accords d'helsinki avoir une corbeille
sécurité une corbeille éducation et
culture une cure bay économie et une
corbeille droits de l'homme voilà c'est
à terme un terme et c'est moi je termine
dessus à terme je crois qu'il faudrait
faire une confédération européenne dans
le domaine économique et culturel
avec tous les pays européens de
l'atlantique à vladivostok jean marc
flipo jaurès réagir à ces quelques
points notamment en ce qui concerne la
sécurité de l'europe et cette question
de la politique de défense européenne
manuel maquereau a déclaré vouloir
profiter de cette présidence pour
trouver une boussole stratégique
mystères du concept déjà c'est pas lui
qui l'a trouvé un cdi à d'ailleurs
appelé du monde a été proposée par
l'allemagne et c'est quelque chose qu'il
est c'est une tendance relativement
lourde puisque toutes les armées
européennes sont confrontées à
la problématique de l'armée
d'échantillons c'est à dire qu'est ce
qu'on fait est ce qu on fait une arme et
d'échantillons comme la france a pu en
avoir par le passé ou est-ce qu'on
s'intègre dans une organisation plus
importants comme le temps donc ça c'est
un sas est une vraie question personne
dans l'après de france malheureusement
aujourd'hui en fait en europe puisque
vous avez des deux armées vous avez dit
vous avez l'armée française vous avez
l'armée britannique l'armée britannique
est sortie de l'union européenne donc on
ne peut plus parler avec elle que en
bilatéral ou à travers à travers le
commandement intégré de l'otan et nous
avons en plus à des problématiques
industrielles c'est à dire que nous
avons une proximité industriel avec les
britanniques mais nous avons des visées
de politique étrangère qui sont
divergentes avec eux et nous avons une
proximité politique avec l'allemagne
mais nous avons des intérêts industriels
qui sont radicaux opposés on l'a vu
encore récemment avec le programme skaff
ou
comment dire le savoir faire
technologique de dassault pour la
composante l'avion de combat a posé deux
est en train d'être pillée par par
l'allemagne on a vu le programme commun
sur le char de combat sur l'avion de
patrouille maritime sur l'hélicoptère de
combat tout ça a volé en éclats donc on
peut pas dire vraiment que en soit en
voie de d'aller vers une meilleure
intégration meilleure coopération qui
donc est ce que nous disons en disant
qu'effectivement l'europe que ce soit
pour la défense ou dans d'autres
domaines rien de culturel etc l'europe
doit être une europe des coopérations
choisi c'est à dire que le voulons
remplacer la commission rappelle par un
secrétariat général un peu qu'un syndic
d'immeuble qui avait pas s'occuper de ce
qui se passe dans chacun des
appartements et que les pays européens
mettrait en place des coopérations
choisie notamment dans le domaine de la
défense peut effectivement les
investissements nécessaires aujourd'hui
sont très importants et se posera à ce
moment là le problème du financement de
cette politique de défense et évidemment
le la clause des 3% là encore devra être
réévaluée parce que vous comprendrez
bien évidemment que entretenir une armée
comme l'armée française ou entretenir
l'armée maltaise rien contre l'armée
maltaise pas de toute condescendance
mais c'est pas exactement le même niveau
d'investissement
jeu philippe mazuel jean-marc chez pas
et vaka l'instant une coopération choisi
ce que c'est
ce que prendrait aussi emmanuel macron
quand on l'entend effectivement abordé
enfin déclaré vouloir aborder la
question des valeurs lorsqu'il sera à la
tête du conseil de l'union européenne il
dit vouloir mener des débats sur l'état
de droit en ajoutant dans la foulée que
ces questions ne sont pas négociables
sont existentielle est ce que cela ne
ferme pas le débat d'emblée avec
certains autres états membres de lieux
non je suis pas d'accord avec certains
sujets avec la présence d'un but mais
sur le celui des valeurs oui je crois
qu'il a raison de vouloir mettre en
avant les valeurs les valeurs de l'union
européenne qui sont d'ailleurs décrite
dans l'article 2 du traité sur l'union
européenne elles sont très claires et
donc à un moment donné quand certains
états enfin certains états un certain
gouvernement remettre en question ses
valeurs il faut être il faut être assez
ferme louis donc là dessus je pense que
c'est que c'est important
en revanche toujours pour revenir sur le
citoyen je crois qu'il n'a pas abordé du
tout la question du multilinguisme il
paraît très important de poser cette
question aujourd'hui parce que comme
vous le savez la langue anglaise a pris
une place prépondérante dans les
institutions européennes et là
maintenant que d'autant que le royaume
uni est sorti de l'union européenne je
pense qu'il faut remettre en question ce
sujet n'a donc certes continuer à
utiliser anglais là où c'est nécessaire
mais donner plus de poids aux autres
langues européennes
français l'allemand l'italien l'espagnol
et un tour de l'ain derniers mois avec
vous je remarque chipeau évidemment à
quatre mois de la présidentielle la
possible candidature du président
sortant à sa réélection était dans tous
les esprits on a senti les journalistes
si elle est un peu à tâtons avant
finalement que la question ne soit très
explicitement poser en toute fin de
conférence de presse on lui a demandé
donc à emmanuel macro s'il l'était
candidat à la présidentielle l'année
prochaine il a refusé d'y répondre est
ce que ça pose problème aujourd'hui dans
ce contexte
oui ça pose problème parce que pour
l'instant ses campagnes déclare jean du
contribuable donc le vrai que le
véritable problème est là tout le monde
personne n'est dupe ainsi demandé à
emmanuel macron ci s'il veut être
candidat à sa réélection c'est un peu
comme demander à un aveugle si le voir
donc tout le monde sait qui va qu'il va
y aller le problème aujourd'hui c'est
que effectivement bayer quand même des
règles dans une élection présidentielle
notamment de comptes de campagne et
aujourd'hui on voit bien que d'une part
donc du fait campagne avec l'argent du
contribuable en plus de ça c'est noël
avant l'heure puisque l'on a vu des
milliards sortir de sa hotte par
dizaines et voire même par centaines et
c'est quand même très très inquiétant
ans et il parle là aujourd'hui de
s'affranchir de la règle des 3% il a
déjà commencé à creuser le déficit
budgétaire dans des proportions
absolument invraisemblable on évoquait
au début de l'été un surfinancement de
la perte d'activité en france de l'ordre
de 200% on a doublement financer la
perte d'activité fraction on a l'air
doit mettre à 500 milliards d'euros deux
qui sont sortis des caisses françaises
cet argent là dans un contexte de retour
de l'inflation il va falloir le
rembourser c'est les français qui va
encore devoir mettre la main à la poche
alors que je vous rappelle quand même
que dans le contexte actuel
énormément d'entreprises en france mais
savent toujours pas comment elles vont
pouvoir rembourser les prêts garantis
par l'état qui leur ont été consentis et
ont un avenir extrêmement merci beaucoup
jean marc flipo porte parle de debout la
france merci à vous également philippe
mazuel président du parti à les citoyens
aux européens voici pour ce décryptage
après la prise de parole des manuels la
mac